so dad we're very happy to have our
whole family here together to celebrate
with you as you receive this honor and
it doesn't get much better than the
Fahlberg award I'm sure everyone here
agrees that you deserve it and not only
for the films that you've made but for
also for the support you've lent to
other filmmakers particularly those who
got their first break from you including
Sophia and myself you've always gone
about your life with the biggest sense
of curiosity and adventure always
including us your family and always
figuring out a way to pull off amazing
achievements against the greatest odds
and despite people who say you couldn't
do it one of my favorite memories as a
kid was and you took our whole family on
a Sunday drive on our 1913 Model T Ford
we drove out to Bolinas from San
Francisco without any seatbelts no
back-up plan and remember the car
overheated on the Golden Gate Bridge but
we got there and this is a great lesson
an inspiration of how to live life and
approach your work that one way we would
get there and maybe have a good story to
tell so thank you for being so
adventurous in your life in your work of
taking us along for the ride and Bravo
to you for your willingness to take big
Gamble's and I think they all paid off
we're so proud of you and you of course
deserve this award and here's your
daughter Sophia and your granddaughter
Gia to lead a toast
you